my rights Tegel Airport shouldn't even
be here a relic of the Cold War when
this was the only air route in and out
of West Berlin now it's showing its age
and government and business alike wanted
shut so a successor elsewhere can open
their plan is to turn this into a
research and industrial park a showpiece
for the 21st century which will
eventually be very lucrative
if you go ahead fast forward 20 years
you would have about 1,000 companies
working here on that common future we
create about 20,000 jobs we generate two
and a half billion in revenues for the
city that equivalent equivalent to
roughly 350 million in tax revenues for
the city the trouble is many aren't so
optimistic almost a million Berliners
voted to keep Tegel open in a referendum
nearly three years ago but as it stands
that verdict is not binding some
politicians wish it was there are many
questions it's not just about the
handling of passengers but there's a
security aspect and also a question of
the traffic situation in Berlin we've
done multiple studies that suggest there
would be huge traffic jams
if the airports are consolidated if
Tegel Airport is shut down and then
there is the ongoing uncertainty over
its successor this will be villi plant
airport or BER to give it a short form
meant to be opened in November 2011 at a
cost of around 2.7 billion dollars
instead a legacy of safety problems has
kept it closed with costs spiralling to
more than eight billion dollars and
Counting if all goes to plan then the
first passengers will be either arriving
at or leaving from this terminal
building at the end of October meaning
these buildings will all be put to the
use that they were originally planned
for almost nine years later some people
say Berlin needs a large airport in
order to be able to compete with other
major European capitals but the fact
remains the overall cost of closing and
opening the relevant airports is now
almost 10 billion dollars
and climbing Dominic Kane al-jazeera in
the German capital